ahora que ya conocemos muy bien los
cuatro números cuánticos vamos a hacer
un poquito de práctica utilizándolos
para pensar sobre las cuatro primeras
capas muy bien así que nuestros primeros
cuatro niveles de energía es lo que
vamos a discutir en este vídeo y vamos a
empezar cuando n es igual a 1 muy bien
es decir estaremos hablando del primer
nivel de energía o nuestra primera capa
muy bien si pensamos en el número
cuántico de momento angular este depende
depende del número cuántico principal
verdad así que cuando n es igual a 1 los
valores posibles para l en este caso van
desde 0 1 2 3 y así sucesivamente hasta
n menos 1 verdad pero n menos 1 en este
caso sería igual a 0 así que tendríamos
que el único valor posible para él es
igual a 0 es el único valor posible para
el número cuántico de momento angular
verdad y sabemos que el igual a cero se
refiere a un orbital
s se refiere a un orbital ese y si
pensamos en el próximo número cuántico
verdad estaríamos hablando del número
cuántico magnético que lo denotamos con
m l y esencialmente el número cuántico
magnético nos dice que cuantas cuantas
orientaciones tienen estos orbitales
verdad de hecho este número cuántico
magnético depende del valor de l ya que
va desde menos l o el negativo hasta l
positivo o más el de verdad así que si
en este caso l es igual a cero tendremos
que el número cuántico magnético es
igual a cero y es el único valor posible
para esto verdad entonces solo podemos
tener una posible orientación de este
orbital s lo cual tiene sentido porque
sabemos que la geometría digamos de este
orbital es esférica es esférica es un
volumen de tres dimensiones y recordemos
que uno
y tal es la región digamos del espacio
en donde es más probable encontrar un
electrón así que tenemos un total de 1
orbital en el primer nivel de energía y
simplemente podríamos haber encontrado
esto verdad simplemente podríamos haber
visto que hay un orbital
con esta fórmula y está verdad que nos
dice el número n elevado al cuadrado y
nos da el número de orbitales que
tenemos en este nivel verdad entonces en
este caso hubiera sido 1 al cuadrado que
es justamente 1 y ese es el número total
de orbitales que vamos a encontrar en
este primer nivel de energía ahora vamos
a fijarnos en los electrones que se
encuentran en cada orbital verdad y lo
que sabemos es que podemos llenar con a
lo más dos electrones en un solo orbital
muy bien así que el cuarto número
cuántico nos dice el espín de un
electrón y que puede ser un medio
positivo
negativo así que si tenemos si tenemos 2
electrones en un orbital uno de ellos
debe tener un spin positivo es decir un
spin un medio positivo y el otro
electrón debe tener el debe tener el
espín un medio negativo verdad así que
hay un máximo de 22 electrones en este
orbital ese muy bien y como es el único
orbital en este nivel de energía o en
esta capa eso será también el número
total de electrones que tenemos en la
capa en total verdad simplemente
tendremos dos y ese es el número total
de electrones ahora también podríamos
haber obtenido este número utilizando la
fórmula de 2n al cuadrado muy bien
porque por qué pues n sería uno en este
caso que elevado al cuadrado sería uno y
al multiplicarlo por dos nos vuelve a
dar dos muy bien vamos a movernos a la
siguiente capa de energía al siguiente
nivel de energía y eso sería el caso en
el que n
es igual a 2 así que si el número
cuántico principal es igual a 2 entonces
el número cuántico de momento angular
bueno habría que pensar cuáles son los
valores posibles para dicho número
cuántico verdad entonces sabemos que
podríamos empezar desde cero y podríamos
tomar todos los valores posibles hasta n
menos 1 que en este caso sería 1
entonces este número cuántico puede ser
0 o 1 así que tenemos dos valores
posibles para el número cuántico de
momento angular verdad si tenemos n en
igualados tendremos dos posibles valores
aquí muy bien ya hemos hablado de eso en
vídeos anteriores entonces cuando él es
igual a cero significa que tendremos un
orbital s verdad y sólo tendremos uno de
ellos tendremos un orbital ese y éste se
encuentra ahora en el segundo nivel de
energía verdad es decir hay hay otro
orbital ese además del que ya habíamos
encontrado estamos pensando que éste
orbital es verdad que se encuentra en el
segundo nivel de energía por supuesto
quizás sería conveniente pintarlo un
poco más grande ya que se refiere a a
una región en el espacio de donde
podríamos encontrar los electrones pero
éstos se encuentran mucho más alejados
del núcleo verdad así que nuestro
electrón se encuentra en promedio mucho
más alejado del núcleo ahora bien cuando
él es igual a uno habría que pensar en
los valores posibles para el número
cuántico magnético así que recordemos
que el número cuántico magnético ml va
desde menos l hasta más l pero en este
caso él es igual a 1 así que tendremos
los valores posibles menos 10 y uno
positivo verdad
así que tenemos tres posibles valores 1
2 y 3 y ahora el número cuántico
magnético nos dice el número total de
posibles orientaciones que pueden tener
estos orbitales verdad y sabemos que
cuando él es igual a 1 entonces nos
referimos a orbitales p muy bien de
hecho sabemos que estos orbitales p
tienen una geometría como demonio como
de mono podríamos pensarlo como como una
pesa además tenemos tres posibles
orientaciones verdad para los orbitales
p
en este segundo nivel de energía uno de
ellos digamos su orientación será a lo
largo del eje x el otro será a lo largo
del eje y y el tercero será a lo largo
del eje z ya hemos hablado de esto en el
vídeo anterior así que cuántos orbitales
en total tenemos en este segundo nivel
de energía bueno tenemos un orbital ese
y tenemos tres orbitales p eso nos da un
total de cuatro orbitales en el segundo
nivel de energía y podríamos haber hecho
las digamos las matemáticas utilizando
esta fórmula n cuadrada verdad en este
caso n es igual a 2 y al elevar 2 al
cuadrado nos da justamente 4 ahora
fijémonos en los electrones tenemos 4
orbitales en total verdad y queremos
saber cuántos electrones tenemos en cada
uno de los orbitales muy bien y
recordemos que a lo más podríamos
colocar dos electrones en cada uno de
estos orbitales así que en el caso en
que hablamos del orbital s en este caso
caben dos verdad en el único orbital es
el que tenemos y si pensamos en los
orbitales p entonces tenemos tres
orbitales p y en cada uno de ellos caben
a lo más dos electrones es decir si
multiplicamos dos por tres dos por tres
tendremos seis electrones posibles así
es que si sumamos dos más seis tendremos
un total de ocho electrones en total en
toda la segunda capa verdad en el
segundo nivel de energía
nuevamente esto podríamos haberlo hecho
utilizando la fórmula que tenemos aquí 2
por n al cuadrado
en este caso es 2 elevado al cuadrado
sería 4 y si multiplicamos por 2 nos da
un total de 8 ahora bien vámonos con el
tercer nivel de energía consideremos el
caso en el que n es igual a 3 y pensemos
nuevamente en los valores posibles para
el número cuántico de momento angular l
este número va desde cero hasta n menos
uno que en este caso sería tres menos
uno son dos así que va desde 0 1 y
llegamos hasta 2 tenemos sólo tres
valores posibles verdad porque en es
igual a 3 tenemos tres valores posibles
para el número cuántico de momento
angular que sería 1 2 y 3 así que como
ya hemos discutido anteriormente cuando
él es igual a cero tendremos un orbital
s cuando él es igual a uno tendremos
orbitales p y serán 3
de ellos y ahora pensemos qué ocurre
cuando l es igual a 2 para ello tenemos
que analizar cuáles son los valores
permitidos para el número cuántico
magnético m l cierto y quizás sería
bueno que utilice otro color en este
caso utilicemos un color azul entonces
si pensamos en el número cuántico
magnético este número depende de él y
sabemos que va desde menos l hasta más l
pero él en este caso es 2 así que
tendremos los valores menos 2 menos 10
+1 y más 2 así que en total tendremos
uno dos tres cuatro cinco valores
posibles para el número cuántico
magnético y eso nos da cinco distintas
orientaciones para este tipo de
orbitales verdad cuando él es igual a
dos en este caso decidimos que tendremos
orbitales de y tenemos cinco
orientaciones distintas para
muy bien 5 orbitales de y vamos a
escribir simplemente hasta ahí
si queremos calcular por ejemplo cuántos
orbitales tenemos en esta en este nivel
de energía simplemente tendremos uno más
tres son cuatro más cinco nos da un
total de nueve orbitales en el tercer
nivel que también podríamos haber
obtenido este número de esta fórmula
verdad tres al cuadrado nos da
exactamente nueve muy bien ahora pasemos
a la siguiente pregunta que es cuántos
electrones caben en en estos orbitales
verdad y ya sabemos que en el orbital s
sólo tenemos uno y por lo tanto caben a
lo más dos electrones en el caso de los
orbitales p tenemos tres de ellos lo
cual nos dice que hay a lo más seis
electrones y en los orbitales después
tenemos cinco de ellos y en cada uno
caben dos por lo tanto 2 por 5 nos da 10
electrones posibles así que si nos
preguntamos cuál es el número total de
electrones que caben en la tercera capa
completa entonces tendríamos que sumar
todos
números verdad 26 son 8 10 nos da 18
nuevamente esto podríamos haberlo hecho
con esta fórmula y está verdad en es
igual a 3 así que tres al cuadrado nos
da nueve si multiplicamos por dos esto
nos da dos por nueve que son 18 la
fórmula es bastante consistente en este
sentido ahora bien sólo nos falta
analizar una cuarta capa verdad y antes
de que hagamos eso quiero mencionar algo
respecto a la forma de los orbitales
porque de hecho ya habíamos dicho que
los orbitales s tienen una figura
digamos una geometría esférica los
orbitales p parecen como monos sin
embargo cuando nos metemos a discutir
los orbitales d empezamos a tener un
poquito de complicación es verdad y
empieza a ser bastante complicado
dibujarlos así que no voy a intentar
dibujar los todos los orbitales d son
digamos cinco distintas orientaciones
así que sólo vamos a saltarnos al cuarto
nivel
simplemente vamos a decir que hay cinco
orbitales de y no vamos a intentar
dibujarlos
pueden buscar por ejemplo en línea
verdad y por eso vámonos a una nueva a
una digamos copie exactamente lo que
teníamos antes para tener espacio y
ahora veamos el caso en el que n es
igual a 4 entonces los valores posibles
de l serían desde cero hasta n menos uno
que en este caso sería 3 ahí tenemos 1 2
y 3 y podemos ver nuevamente que el
número total de valores posibles para l
coincide con el valor de n y digamos
repitiendo todos los argumentos que ya
teníamos en el caso en el que él es
igual a cero tendremos un orbital s en
el caso en el que él es uno tendremos
orbitales p en el caso en el que él es
igual a 2 ya dijimos que son orbitales
de y cuando tengamos el igual a 3
decimos que los orbitales son orbitales
efe muy bien y spd y efe las letras que
le dan nombre a los orbitales provienen
de una vieja nomenclatura que se
utilizaba en espectroscopia atómica y es
digamos en realidad ya no sé
sanz más ok así que de ahí es de donde
vienen las letras que utilizamos
simplemente para pensar en los orbitales
verdad y sus distintas formas así que
cuando hablamos del orbital ese tiene
una figura de una de una esfera y
sabemos que sólo tenemos uno de ellos
cuando tenemos orbitales p tenemos tres
de ellos y tienen forma de moño de pesa
cuando tenemos orbitales de tenemos
cinco y bueno es difícil dibujarlos pero
ahora pensemos en los orbitales
efe y hay que pensar cuántos tenemos de
los orbitales
efe para lo cual nuevamente hay que
analizar el valor m l que es el número
cuántico magnético así que cuántos
podríamos tener
bueno pues sabemos que estos van de
menos l hasta más el entonces esto va
desde menos 3 - 2 - 1 0 1
2 y 3 así que si contamos cuántos de
estos tenemos serían 1 2 3 4 5 6 y 7
tenemos un total de 7 valores de siete
orientaciones distintas para los
orbitales
efe muy bien ahora con esto ya podríamos
ver el máximo número de electrones en
cada uno en cada uno de los distintos
tipos de orbitales vamos a utilizar otro
color digamos digamos este que tenemos
aquí este está muy muy bien así que
pensemos cuántos cuantos electrones
perdón caben en el orbital ese pues
serían sólo dos si tenemos tres
orbitales pei en cada uno caben dos
tendríamos seis en total si tenemos
cinco orbitales de podríamos tener diez
electrones y ahora bien si tenemos 77
orbitales
efe entonces tendremos un máximo de 14
electrones que serían 2 por 7 en los
orbitales
y si quisiéramos saber cuál es el número
total de electrones que pueden caber en
esta cuarta capa simplemente hay que
sumar verdad 2 + 6 son 8 8 + 10 son 18 y
18 + 14 nos da un total de 32 electrones
en la cuarta en el cuarto nivel de
energía ahora bien otra vez si
utilizáramos esta fórmula tendríamos que
n es 4 4 al cuadrado son 16 y si
multiplicamos esto por 2 nos da un total
de 32 así que espero que con este vídeo
ya tengas mucha más intuición y mucha
más experiencia jugando con los números
cuánticos y en realidad es son un
ejercicio muy útil sentarse y pensar en
cómo es que los números cuánticos
dependen los unos con los otros verdad
por ejemplo l depende del número n iv ml
el número cuántico magnético depende de
l a su vez así que esto nos va a dar un
poco de intuición para poder comprender
la tabla periódica
configuraciones electrónicas